I am not a bad guy I am a good guy who
runs over women with his
car I'm sorry that was so good damn it
I'm not a bad guy I'm a good guy who
runs over women with his
car everyone loves a good comeback story
right SE Biscuit the Mighty Ducks Robert
dowy Jr who else Rocky yes Kim
Kardashian Kim well well in the video
she gets she gets come on her back I
think what the hell does that mean means
whatever the hell you want it to me
you're saying you want a piece of
[Applause]
me
hiot
tiot shut up shut shut up shut up my
George isn't clever enough to hatch a
scheme like this you got that right what
the hell does that
[Applause]
mean what the hell
the come on okay let's go let's go
you saying you want a piece of
me say that one more
time your mom called she needs you home
right away is everything okay no I don't
think so it's your
grandma it's your
grandma
yeah no no I don't think
so the bird's get a message to the good
masters of asapo the wise masters of
Yong Kai and the benevolent
benevolent tell me can your little birds
get a message to the good masters of
asapo the wise masters of yonai and the
benan and the benevent and the
benevolent it's your
[Music]
grandma it's wrong with you I don't know
it's your
grandma that word is so funny I can't do
I like that one too tell me can you
little birds get a message to the good
masters of asapo the wise masters of
Yong Kai the Ben elevant enslavers of
[__] you saying you want a piece of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
me from now on I am Kevin Cosner your
balls are Whitney Houston
rip what
come on everybody hates us come on I
know I'm not sorry so sorry everybody
you little birds get a message to the
good masters of vast the wise masters of
yonai and the benevolence enslavers of
[__] I had it too and the Ben benevolent
sorry ready tell
me [__] me I got it I got it nice oh
yeah yeah how did you get
this you shattered you shattered it no
you yes I will be your ballsy Guard from
now on I am Kevin Cosner your balls are
Whitney Houston rip what Whitney died
yeah oh my god oh how's Michael Jackson
taking
it I had it too you son of a I lost it
that's going to be a little harder to
fix sorry I'm
out
H what are you doing here Hi how are you
hi I'm not in character
yet you know the song sing
[Applause]
[Music]
along from now on I am Kevin Cosner your
balls are Whitney Houston oh rip she
died yeah what oh my god oh no
oh come on you got I know you got to
hang with
[Applause]
it what oh my god oh no Whitney's
dead
I need to be able to look at you
man can I ask you something I always
wanted to ask the real Batman yeah since
you're a big bat can you turn into a
tiny vampire anytime any
place do it
now don't do it
now don't do it freak everybody out here
freak everybody out we'll do it later I
don't want to freak you out I don't want
to freak me
out see uh this elephant had this little
dwarf trainer and
uh just used to put a little ballerina
skirt on that
elephant what's going on okay I thought
you were in love with your brother Ryan
right what's Ryan think about all this
Ryan's dead oh really to me he's
dead yeah let's just do let's do
this I'm not goodby
[__] [__] [__] up all of my can I ask
you something I always want to ask a
real Batman yeah are you my
uncle
Troy are we going to
[Music]
kiss's
I hit
[Applause]
you
oh there's a rumor going around the
circus
that that dwarf and the Elephant were
lovers sounds like the 70s a bunch of
people would get together and the next
thing you know it was all hands and
butts and tits and wo I could just slip
right in there and out nobody would know
the difference it was great then AIDS
ruined
everything can I ask you a question that
I always want to ask the real Batman go
for
it Wonder Woman yeah you hit that all
day she was my
first Wonder Woman that's what's
up you know it's a chasity B right do
Chassy oh I had to shoot the
H I don't know whether it's CU of the
rumor or not but they're buried
together great big
tombstone he was raping
you
yeah yeah I guess so yes both of you no
no that can't rap that can't rap too got
no just my friend here he got it the
worst I shook the guy off in time
no so who's only raping
you can I can I ask you something I
always want to ask the real Batman yeah
why your movie so
good don't it's not funny I guess what
surround sound means is that right over
here
CH two
speakers damn we have two
speakers what honey oh Jesus no just my
friend here he he got at the worst I I
shook the guy off in time he never quite
made it inside of me but yeah he's only
raping you no apparently yeah I didn't
see but I guess he didn't I guess he
never actually check this out
folds the wall
I can hear you why are you calling me my
minutes won't roll over I have to use
them
today okay there's a press release that
Ryan would like I can hardly hear
you just stop trying to do this and
admit that you're in
danger uh uh I know I used to be a
temper and now I'm your boss and I
understand how that must be weird for
you but
you I'm really sorry I broke that was
too good